ça suffit il faut ramener de la
rationalité la rationalité c'est qu'il y
a des milliers et des milliers de
travailleurs aujourd'hui qui sont
exploités et il faut mettre fin à
[Musique]
ça on parle de travailleurs qui sont en
irrégularité du point de vue du droit du
séjour mais en régularité du point de
vue du droit du travail c'est ça notre
difficulté on parle de gens qui sont
déjà sur le sol national et qui ont des
fiches de paye et parfois des contrats
de travail et ces gens qui ont des
fiches de paye payent des impôts avec
l'impôt à la source puisque un taux
neutre s'applique paye des cotisations
et pour autant non pas les droits qui
relèvent du travailleur donc il y a deux
solutions soit on expulse ces personnes
en commençant par condamner les
entreprises qui embauchent les personnes
de cette manière bien soit on régularise
une partie ou toute partie de ces
personnes le problème c'est que le droit
aujourd'hui ne permet de faire ni l'un
ni l'autre d'abord par rapport à la
version initiale en lieu et place de
l'automaticité générale et absolue de
toute régularisation dans les métiers en
tenstion nous souhaitions que le préfet
a son mot à dire mais à l'inverse du
Sénat nous souhaitions que le préfet ne
puisse pas disposer d'un pouvoir
discrtionnaire et raison pour laquelle
je j'ai proposé et je l'ai indiqué dans
mes propos liminires il y a déjà
quelques heures que lorsque la personne
introduise sa demande de régularisation
d'abord qu'elle soit en autonomie
complète vis-à-vis de l'employeur je
rappelle les liens de subordination je
rappelle les liens parfois
d'exploitation et puis ensuite de faire
en sorte que le préfet à tout moment au
cours de la procédure de demande de
régularisation puisse s'y opposer pour
des raisons tenants aux menaces à
l'ordre public je pense que nous sommes
tous d'accord pour considérer que nous
ne pouvons pas accepter de régulariser
quelqu'un qui pourrait troubler l'ordre
publicou qui aurait commis des des faits
qui provoquaient des troubles à l'ordre
public de la même façon que toute forme
d'agissement contraire aux principes et
valeurs de la République nous paraîtrait
tout à fait inacceptable vous avez
supprimé les quotas vous avez rétabli
l'ame vous avez supprimé le délit de
séjour irrégulier et avec cet article 4
bis vous consacrez un droit à
régularisation pour les personnes en
situation irrégulières dans les métiers
en tension elle devient de droit vous
créez donc un droit opposable et des
sources de contentieux probablement
infinie alors nous nous sommes c'est une
4è ligne rouge nous sommes frontalement
opposé à cette disposition ce texte vise
à créer une nè filière d'immigration
alors vous avez beau essayer de prendre
tout un tas de précautions en nous
disant que ces régularisations bah
d'abord ça va être à titre expérimental
mais on sait très bien comment ça se
passe c'est toujours pérénisé par la
suite on nous dit mais vous inquiétez
pas il y a une liste de métiers en
tenstion mais comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure il y a un risque réel que sous
les sous la pression des associations
immigrationnistes et de l'extrême gauche
il y a un élargissement de ces métiers
en tenstion on nous dit vous inquiétez
pas ça correspondra qu'à certaines zones
géographiques sauf que vu les
amendements qu'on a déjà vu passer il y
a un risque que finalement toute la
France soit reconnue comme une zone
géographique tendue je voudrais qu'on
arrête de tenter de répondre un temps
soit peu à cette idée l'appel d'air
n'existe pas il est un mythe complet et
ça suffit que vous vous saisissiez et
vous glissier vers cette idée en y
répondant de manière rationnelle c'est
un mythe total et il n'y a pas de
rationalité à cette idée là donc stop et
vos amendements en permanence quand vous
les défendez aujourd'hui et bien vous
avez l'impression que en accordant à
1000 travailleurs de plus dans l'année
parce qu'en réalité au fur et à mesure
on est sur quelques petits milliers et
bien vous créez une bombe politique ça
suffit